certains n'hésitent pas à la plongée
dans l'eau d'autres préfèrent
l'accrocher au mur
peu importe son utilisation lara si oui
à transformer la rame traditionnelle
huronne un objet contemporain biais
populaire c'est parti ici sur l'étendue
nionwentsïo auparavant et ses premières
nations utilisait beaucoup les larmes
pour faire du commerce
parce qu'ils faisaient beaucoup de
cadeaux pour justement faire du truc
donc aujourd'hui je trouve que ça fait
un beau symbole de pont entre justement
est les communautés autochtones qui les
autres nations la gène mann d'analysé
sur ce symbole pour tisser ses propres
fonds commerciaux ces rames sont vite
devenus des objets décoratifs qui ont
fait qu'on va utiliser beaucoup des
couleurs qui sont air des couleurs qui
viennent nous rechercher le gendre ça
peut représenter le soleil tu sais tout
le temps des choses comme ça c'est une
inspiration du moment puis par la suite
on y voit lui donner un nom qu'elle se
lâche la seule depuis la fondation de
son entreprise il y a deux ans lara
estime avoir vendu 4000 ram
elles se vendent entre 65 et 150 dollars
la maison simons les distribuer à
travers le canada et les européens en
raffolent mais aussi des boutiques en
europe en suisse nous ont demandé dans
le fond nous faire une vraie de faire
des livraisons à grande échelle
en quoi ta compte un seul employé et
lara ne peut pas pour l'instant si
consacrer à temps plein si bien que la
production ne fournit tout simplement
pas son enfant durant quatre à cinq par
jour puis si on réussit là à voir
l'atelier le but c'est d'employer le
plus possible pour en faire faire le
plus possible parce qu'on on a beaucoup
de demandes qui on répond pas
nécessairement la langue
parmi ceux qui placent des commandes le
grand chef huron wendat toujours dans
toutes les rencontres chrono konrad
sioui s'en sert aussi pour laisser sa
trace et sceller des alliances surtout
beaucoup de ministres québécois que
puits canadien qui n'auront pas la face
il faut aussi pour toutes les premières
nations que même les canadiens et
québécois un peu partout dans le monde
c'est ça la vraie histoire a pas été
facile pour tous et chacun
et faut mettre certaines choses en
arrière de nous qu'ils vont le positif
puis avant tout c'est l'as rome s'est un
peu sur cessé d'avancer aussi dans le
futur
puis pour ce changement un symbole qui
espère qu'elle permettra de ramener
ensemble dans la même direction
et si valérie gamache radio canada sur
les termes you in this you de la réserve
faunique des laurentides